great news everybody we found out about
a new character Jim Broadbent is playing
on Game of Thrones he explained what's
going on so I'm going to do a breakdown
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far if
you don't know what's going on Jim
Broadbent was announced is a big
character for season seven but we didn't
know how big of a character he was going
to be so he didn't interview recently
where he revealed a bunch of stuff
without getting super spoilery but it
points to a couple big things from the
folks that we've suspected for a while
so there's a new round of the game of
Thrones giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video I'm giving away the
enhanced editions of the books you can
actually read about the character that I
think that he is that I'll explain so
right off the bat I think he's playing
Marwyn the mage he was the person I
suspected when he was initially
announced but he could have been anybody
because Ian McShane was cast and we had
no idea who he was playing til he did
that very famous tits & Dragons
interview where he's like it's no big
deal I'm not spoiling anything and he
explained that he was only going to be
this one-off character and we know that
they killed him off right away so even
though he was amazing he was barely on
the show it's a raisin yo silly there's
a reason I'm a big spot on I'm tough to
kill no reason gods on DOMA you yeah
well there's plenty of playas does it
makes you think they know the word of
god or gods
I don't I don't even know their real
names maybe it is a seven or maybe it's
the old gods well maybe it's the Lord of
Light or maybe they're all the same
thing I don't know Jim Broadbent
on the other hand he didn't say who his
name was said that he was going to be in
about five episodes that's five of seven
episodes so that means we're going to
see him almost every single week and
because he's going to be a maester he'll
be with Samwell storyline and it sounds
like that's how Samwell is going to get
a bunch of the information that he needs
information about White Walkers in the
night King information about the wall
itself the politics and history of
Westeros the Targaryen restoration any
technical information that we might need
so what it sounds like they might do is
because there's so much information to
convey is that they'll just split the
technical information that we need for
jim broadbent character through Samwell
storyline and then the more
emotional stuff that we need to learn
like Jon Snow's parentage through brands
character because brand has faced the
night king he's gone to the Past seen
jon snow be born so there's so much that
he can convey to but it sounds like
they're not going to have him do the
entire info-dump that we're going to
need to get and kind of the funny thing
about that is that the actor who plays
brand also sort of did a preview for his
character so I'll have to do a separate
video about that but he said that he
finished filming his scenes really early
on like they've been filming ever since
the end of last year he said they
finished months ago doing all the brand
stuff so let the speculation fly about
what that says about his presence in
season 7
it also helps justify familes trip to
the Citadel he needs to learn to become
a maester it's a big part of book 5
we've already crossed most of that
storyline so the characters that he runs
into where he learns about all these
cool things about Daenerys and her
dragons is Marwyn the mage if that does
turn out to be who jim broadbent is
playing it sounds like they're going to
make some changes to his character from
the book because the book character
spends most of his time hanging out with
degenerate hedge wizards people down at
the docks in bars so the other arch
maesters of the Citadel really don't
like him because he has so much interest
in the occult but what do we need to
learn we need to learn about Daenerys
dragons the knight King that is prime
occult territory so he is one of the
most important people right now
and even though the books are vastly
different from the TV show in the books
he actually wants to become Daenerys as
maester because she has her own new
small council she's forming around her
but she doesn't really have her own
maester around the other funny thing
about this is that sort of the impetus
for Samwell going to the Citadel
to learn to become a maester is all for
maester aemon who he himself tried to
become part of the nurses small Council
now because he was so old he died during
the voyage to Old Town so in the books
he dies he died at the wall on the TV
show so it just seems like so many
characters are trying to help Daenerys
around it's just so funny that maester
aemon was like oh my god I'm a Targaryen
I need to go be the main strip for
Daenerys she needs my help
Samwell you go learn to be the maester
so you can come back and take my place
and then separately you have Marwan
going oh my god I need to become
Daenerys
or two completely independent to that so
it sounds like most of Sam wealth
storyline will either take place at the
Citadel or if he does leave then jim
broadbent character will travel with him
and just continue to explain things in
that old professorial voice conversely
it seems like Daenerys is going to be
spending most of her time on the eastern
side of Westeros like you see them
painting all these ships here this looks
like her massing her fleet down in Dorne
heading up the coast thinking about
King's Landing that doesn't mean that
she's heading straight there it just
means that most of her focus is going to
be on their jim broadbent character
could try to travel to her because it's
really unlikely that Daenerys herself
would come to the Citadel for any reason
even though it's really important she
relies on Tyrion for most of her
information right now and even though he
has studied as the Citadel before he's
no maester
he's very learned but there's still so
many things in the books that he's
learning as he goes along one of the
really cool things is that he does start
to learn about dragons as he's meeting
with a Gon's character but that's a
storyline and characters that they've
cut out of the TV show so it makes sense
that they would use jim broadbent
character is this really big explainer
character to tie a lot of the storylines
together so if you haven't seen anything
with them he plays that type of
character in most of the movies that
he's in most recently he is known for
playing Professor Slughorn and the Harry
Potter films this really wise a learned
person with a checkered past so Marlon
is kind of like that you may have heard
about the maesters really hating the
idea of magic there's a lot of ideas
about maesters having a conspiracy to
get rid of magic in the world I don't
know that it's necessarily true but
they're definitely biased against magic
is all about science even though when
you go to the Citadel to learn to become
a maester and forge your chain each of
the links representing a different area
of study there is a Valyrian link that
you can get by studying magic in the
occult but most maesters in the world
don't have it there are very few that
actually do one of the really cool
things about Marwan is that he wrote a
book called the book of lost books
meaning that he has a lot of knowledge
that's thought to been lost so we're
talking about deep mythology to God the
war for the dawn things that are so
important for the final seasons
the show is part of that book he claims
to have found part of another book that
was lost that has collections of Danis
The Dreamers visions now she's a
Targaryen way back before the doom of
Valyria is part of the Targaryen family
who had visions of the doom causing her
father to pack up their family take
their dragons everything they own
leave the Valyrian freehold and travel
to Dragonstone so that they could escape
the doom no idea that book will show up
on the TV show but they usually find
funny ways to include Easter eggs where
characters mention books or you see it
sitting on a shelf somewhere so we'll
just have to keep our eyes peeled when
the episode drops but this is so great
Jim Broadbent is such a great actor and
I cannot wait to hear what he has to say
about the grand history of the world let
me know how do you think they're going
to split the information that we need to
get from the riders between brand in
between this maestra character now we
can think of him as Marwan for now but
they haven't officially confirmed who
he's going to be just that he's really
important and seems to know all of the
things that Marwan knows in the books
but it just sounds like what's going to
happen is is that brand will be the
character who will tell Jon Snow look I
have this vision of your family and then
tried to explain it to him
jim broadbent character will be the one
who has all the evidence to back that up
because it sounds like even though brand
has a lot of information he has great
powers he doesn't fully understand them
yet it doesn't really have the technical
knowledge or the standing to impress the
other lords of the north like you could
tell everyone that Jon Snow's father is
Rhaegar Targaryen in that the night king
is this terrible creation of the
children of the forest but if you don't
have any evidence to back that up or any
sort of clout in the kingdom then the
lords won't believe you and they won't
back you that's the big problem is that
you need the information but you also
need the credibility to back that up so
it sounds like old professor maester
character will be the one to tell
Samwell look at these Scrolls over here
in this part of the library that's where
the evidence you need is and they'll
help Samwell become a maester as well
but because the show is so condensed it
actually takes many many years to become
a maester so it sounds like Samwell is
either going to have to leave early or
just get a crazy crash course in
whatever it is that he needs so that he
can get back to the wall the really cool
thing about marwan's that connects a lot
of
the different characters and storylines
on the show is that he spent a lot of
time traveling in the East he went to a
shy he learned about shadow binders he
spent time studying in a part of the
world that values mystical information
as much as the maesters value scientific
information so that's the place where
Melisandre comes from so she keeps
talking about the war for the dawn but
nobody trusts her anymore
so hopefully jim broadbent character
will add some credibility to that but
i'm expecting these because they're only
going to be seven episodes they'll sort
of condense his backstory down to a
character who just been all over the
world and learned all kinds of things in
his aware of the teachings of the red
God like he will know what's going on if
he runs into Melisandre but all really
good stuff so what's going to happen
next is is this a big panel happening on
Sunday for South by Southwest let me
know if you want me to do that brand
video before then just talking about his
character specifically based on what
Isaac Hempstead Wright talked about so
if we're going to do that I'll try to
post that in the next couple days but
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
happening so I'll try to get it out as
fast as possible
while you wait for that to post you can
click here for all those brand new
teasers they just post it and you can
click here for all my Logan Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video
you